à quelques jours du réveillon du nouvel
an tu des idées de repas préparés chez
soi avec un traiteur de luxe pour ceux
qui succombent à la mode du cocktail
dînatoire mais comme le montre ce grand
chef qu'on rencontrait virginie timothy
kaine avait pozzo on peut aussi en
mettre plein la vue pour pas cher
une valse de couleurs et de formes
subtiles la haute gastronomie se change
en haute couture pour séduire et
intrigué avant même de régaler le
cocktail dînatoire est devenu tendance
pour les fêtes de fin d'année une
alternative à la cuisine traditionnelle
ce traiteur se veut créateur foie gras
de canard à la gelée de lavande crème
brûlée salé est truffé un véritable
travail d'orfèvre pour amuser tous les
sens des convives les gens veulent des
choses différentes le pull vraiment se
mettre à table pour pour le réveillon du
31 contrairement à noël donc les gens
veulent recevoir veulent s'amuser
veulent profiter les gens qui invite
veulent profiter de leurs invités et le
cop tête c'est un petit peu
la clé de l'invitation surprendre ses
invités avec un repas sans trop dépenser
et centre au fusil mais c'est possible
conseils de grands chefs pour une
fricassée de noix de coquilles saint
jacques au beurre de pommes et au corail
d'oursin on va colorer le mont saint
jean avec un tout petit peu de bonheur
ils ont déjà été assaisonnez de sel de
poids donc ses tenues préférées
bref passage dans la poêle pour les noix
de saint-jacques rencontre furtive de
l'eau bouillante et des poires aux
épinards et puis la clé de la recette
les oursins dans du beurre de pommes
tout simplement 30 g de beurre fondu
dans du jus de pomme
c'est moi qui ai créé ce que je
cherchais à contrebalancer ce côté iodé
d'oursins donc l'idée m'est venue de la
pomme qui vraiment fait le lien avec
source à la fom le végétal la subtilité
dans la simplicité
de quoi réaliser à la maison un repas de
réveillon dennis des plus grands palaces